THIS IS A FOX NEWS ALERT.
I AM BRET BAIER IN WASHINGTON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THE PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN COULD LAST
MONTHS OR MORE THAN A YEAR,
ALTHOUGH HE UPS NEGOTIATIONS
WILL BE FRUITFUL IN COMING DAYS.
BUT THE PRESIDENT ALSO SAYS HE
IS CONSIDERING DECLARING A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY IN ORDER TO
BUILD HIS BORDER WALL WITH OR
WITHOUT CONGRESS.
THE STATEMENTS COME ON THE DAY
THE STOCK MARKET SEARCHED ON
HIGHER-THAN-EXPECTED JOBS
NUMBERS FOR DECEMBER AND THE
FEDERAL RESERVE CHAIR SAYING HE
WILL BE PATIENT WITH INTEREST
RATE HIKES.
FOX NEWS COVERAGE TONIGHT, DOUG
CALLOWAY IS ON CAPITOL HILL,
DEMOCRATS FIRMLY ENTRENCHED
AGAINST THE PRESIDENTS PORTABLE.
KEVIN CORKE STARTS US OFF FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE THE
PRESIDENT SEEMS EQUALLY
COMMITTED TO HIS POSITION.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
CONSIDERING THOSE EMERGENCY
POWERS TO GRANT HIMSELF THE
AUTHORITY TO SOMEHOW FIND THE
WALL WITHOUT CONGRESSIONAL
APPROVAL, THE PRESIDENT SAID,
YES, HE THOUGHT ABOUT IT AND
YES, HE WOULD DO IT, IF IT CAME
TO THAT.
JUST THE VERY LATEST TWIST IN
THE ONGOING DEBATE ABOUT FUNDING
THE WALL AND ENDING THE PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
>> WE COULD ABSOLUTELY CALL A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY BECAUSE OF
THE SECURITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
ABSOLUTELY.
NO, WE CAN DO IT.
I HAVEN'T DONE IT.
I MAY DO IT.
BUT WE CAN CALL A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND BUILD IT VERY
QUICKLY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY ON THE
HEELS OF A TWO HOUR MEETING WITH
DEMOCRATS HERE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> WE JUST COMPLETED A LENGTHY
AND SOMETIMES CONTENTIOUS
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> WE HAD A VERY, VERY
PRODUCTIVE MEETING.
>> TWO VIA POINTS OF A VERY
IMPORTANT MEETING WITH A
SINGULAR PURPOSE, TO ENTER
PERSONAL          PARTIAL GOVERM
PERSONAL          PARTIAL GOVERH
PERSONAL          PARTIAL GOVERT
PERSONAL          PARTIAL GOVERO
PERSONAL          PARTIAL GOVERN
PERSONAL          PARTIAL GOVER.
>> I'M NOT SAYING IT WAS IT
EASY, KIND, OR NICE MEETING BUT
IN THE END, WE COME A LONG WAY.
WE WILL BE WORKING VERY HEART OF
THE WEEKEND.
>> THE SECOND SUCH GATHERING
FROM LEADERS FROM BOTH PARTIES
AND
AN END THE SITUATION ROOM.
WHILE NEITHER SIDE WHICH ARE
SPECIFICS ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION, THE CONSENSUS WAS
THAT THERE IS MORE WORK TO BE
DONE.
>> THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS A
DANGEROUS, HORRIBLE DISASTER.
WE'VE DONE A GREAT JOB, BUT YOU
CAN'T REALLY DO THAT KIND OF
DROP WE HAVE TO DO UNLESS YOU
HAVE A MAJOR POWERFUL BARRIER,
AND THAT IS WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE.
>> OUR AIM WILL BE TO FIND A
SOLUTION, NOT JUST SIMPLY TO END
THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, TO
PROVIDE FUNDING TO END THE
CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN BORDER TO
ACHIEVE REAL BORDER SECURITY AND
TO BUILD A WALL ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
>> THE WALL, THE PILLAR OF THE
PRESIDENT'S PROMISE TO DEFEND
THE BORDER AND AN ABSOLUTE
NONSTARTER FOR DEMOCRATS, WHO
VOWED TO STAND UNTIL THE
PRESIDENT REOPENS THE GOVERNMEN
GOVERNMENT.
>> WE HAVE A DISAGREEMENT ON THE
REFUSAL OF THE PRESIDENT TO OPEN
UP THE GOVERNMENT.
>> WITH THE IMPASSE NOW IN 14
DAYS AND COUNTING, THE PROSPECTS
OF A QUICK SOLUTION SEEM
CONSIDERABLY MURKY AT BEST.
>> IT'S VERY HARD TO SEE HOW
PROGRESS WILL BE MADE UNLESS
THEY OPEN UP THE GOVERNMENT.
>> I THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE AND
REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE.
THEY FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT
HAVING A SAFE COUNTRY, HAVING A
BORDER THAT MAKES SENSE.
WITHOUT BORDERS, I'VE SAID IT
MANY TIMES, WE DON'T HAVE A
COUNTRY.
I HOPE IT DOES NOT GO ON EVEN
BEYOND A FEW MORE DAYS.
>> AND THE MEETINGS, BRET,
CONTINUE TO MILE, BOTH AT 11:00
AT 1:00, INCLUDING THE
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE AS
THEY TRY TO END THE IMPASSE.
OF ANOTHER QUICK NOTE, SENIOR
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS ARE
SAID TO RECEIVE $10,000 ANNUAL
RAISES BEGINNING TOMORROW, AND
WHILE TODAY THE VICE PRESIDENT
SAID HE WOULD TURN DOWN HIS
RAISE, THE PRESIDENT SAID HE
WOULD CONSIDER ASKING OTHER
SENIOR OFFICIALS TO FOLLOW SUIT.
BRET?
>> Bret: KEVIN CORKE, THE
PRESIDENT PRESENT TO DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY TO BUILD THE
WALL.
SO CAN HE ACTUALLY DO NOT?
>> LISTEN, MOST PEOPLE SAY NO,
HE CAN'T DO THAT, BRET.
BUT I THINK A BETTER ANSWER IS
HE DEPENDS BECAUSE WHILE
LEGALLY, HE CANNOT WITHOUT
CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL SAY, TAKE
MONEY FROM ONE PART IN THE
FEDERAL BUDGET AND MOVE IT TO
ANOTHER TO BUILD A WALL, OTHER
LEGAL SCHOLARS ALWAYS WARN US
ABOUT THE BROAD NATURE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S POWER UNDER NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
EITHER WAY, IF HE ATTEMPTED TO